best for soil crop rotation practical
information
hi I'm Saskia and I work at Delfy a
research and advisory service in arable
farming to manage a good soil health is
a sound crop rotation of great
importance how you do that and
everything that comes with it you can
see in this best for soil video a good
crop rotation can help to prevent crop
damage by pests and diseases while also
increasing and maintaining soil health
beside prevention of pests and diseases
it plays a major role in soil fertility
and structure crop rotation is a planned
order of growing specific crops on the
same field the succeeding crop belongs
to a different family in order to press
soil borne diseases and nematodes a
rotation can be kept very simple but the
more diverse the more benefits can be
utilized under the precondition that the
specific crops are used in the right
sequence and ratio to design an
appropriate crop rotation it is
important to understand the underlying
processes and to follow the right steps
soil borne diseases and nematodes
require a susceptible host plant in
order to survive and multiply they can
multiply in or on the infected
susceptible host plant
after harvest crop residues and dead
plants will potentially contain huge
amounts of pathogens and nematodes with
the decomposition of the crop residues
and plants they will be retained in the
soil thereby increasing the level of
infestation in the soil
this increases the pressure on the next
crop to the point that its cultivation
is possibly not economically feasible
anymore this continuous cycle can be
interrupted by growing a non host crop
that is not susceptible to the diseases
and nematodes present in the soil
this action harnesses natural factors
such as starving of the pathogen or
antagonism by beneficial soil
microorganisms meaning that the
populations of the pathogens and
nematodes will decline to the point that
potentially susceptible crops can be
grown successfully again in the same
soil
crop rotation prevents pests and
diseases reaching a population density
in which they affect crop yield and
quality resulting in an economic loss
for the farmer
it increases or preserves soil health
and thus helps to maintain the prof
ability of the crop
of all a sound crop rotation is adapted
to the local conditions
apart from market opportunities and soil
type the infestation level of already
present diseases and pests determines
the rotation scheme
determination of the soil infestation
level by nematodes is relatively easy
and in many countries public or private
laboratories offer such services in
contrast only a few of such methods
exist for soil borne fungal pathogens
for example for verticillium and this
analysis is only available in a limited
number of countries
therefore a sound rotation is especially
important to manage fungal soil borne
diseases the host range for soil borne
diseases and nematodes has to be taken
into account some diseases and nematodes
have a rather narrow host range for
example potato cyst nematodes while
others have a wide host range such as
Trick odorous spp
the design of the crop rotation is
highly dependent on the crops and which
diseases or nematodes are already
present in the field here we will design
a sound crop rotation with the help of
the best for soil database one example
is a field on a sandy soil in northern
Europe we have a rotation of 8 years the
main crops are potato onion and carrot
typical soil borne diseases and
nematodes for these crops of
verticillium Dahlia Sclerotinia sclera
tiem Fusarium former terrestris Alton
Aria reddit Xena free living nematodes
the nematodes prati lenka's penetrance
and turkey doris SPP within this
rotation we grow potato two times and
the other crops are sugar beet cabbage
and winter wheat with rye as green
manure crop
a general rule for the frequency is to
grow a crop no more than once in the two
or more years for many crops however a
longer period is required in this
rotation for example the main crop
potato is alternated by three sequences
of other crops soil analysis and
observations from previous crops show
that the following nematodes are present
in the field the nematode pretentious
penetrance and the nematode trick
odorous SPP the level of nematode
pretentious penetrance is above the
damage threshold therefore we look into
the best for soil database to see which
non host plants we can grow
after filling in our proposed rotation
the scheme shows at which level a
nematode could multiply on the chosen
crops and at which level the crops
suffer from the nematode
as we see here trick odorous is not
always harmful but multiplies on all
crops
therefore we decide to introduce the
cover crop target is Petula
since target Asst releases a substance
deadly for pretentious when these
nematodes entered the plant we see that
another weakness of our plan is the
sequence of winter wheat and the choice
for Rye
because pretentious multiplies strongly
on rye while only a little on sugar beet
even better options instead of rye our
Japanese oat and summer barley so we
decided to switch sugar beet with summer
Bali and replace rye by Japanese oat and
target is as green manures
this is an example of an improved crop
rotation in the best for soil factsheet
about crop rotation you find more
examples of rotation designs such as a
typical arable rotation in northern
Europe of winter wheat potato and winter
oil seed rape
other considerations when designing a
crop rotation will now briefly be
discussed in this video
some crops are grown after each other to
complement each other's needs a lei Xun
forage crop which fixes nitrogen can be
grown before a crop which demands high
nitrogen levels
a deep-rooted crop such as summer barley
can be grown after crops such as sugar
beets to improve the soil structure and
water infiltration
deep rooting crops bring back nutrients
which were leached to deeper soil layers
instead of leaving the soil bare after
harvesting the main crops you can grow
cover crops after all crops harvested no
later than October the first
be aware that also for cover crops you
should consider the nematode levels in
relation to host and non host plants
other crops prevent leaching of
nutrients leave residues to maintain
soil organic matter levels they protect
the soil surface and feed the soil food
web cover crops also promote the
formation of highly stable soil
aggregates that can resist eroding from
heavy rainfalls and winds
learn more about cover crops in the best
for soil videos about cover crops and
green manures to get the most out of
your rotation where possible integrate
with other practices such as cover crops
in any case consider which parasitic
nematodes and diseases you have or
expect to have and adjust your rotation
and choice of cover crops green manure
to reduce them the best for soil
database can be used to choose the right
crop for your situation to design a
sound crop rotation
you